la question à présent qui ressort
gagnant le président russe Vladimir
Poutine qui a maintenu l'ordre ou bien
et Ève gagné Prigogine qui a osé défier
l'état major russe nous avons interrogé
à ce sujet notre chroniqueur Bruno
darwui écouter
sans doute un peu des deux pour chacun
parce que Vladimir Poutine finalement a
montré qu'il restait faire mais
finalement été relativement conciliant
envers Gagny Prigogine à cause des
raisons que j'invoquais à cause aussi
des liens personnels malgré tout qui
existent entre les deux hommes depuis
très longtemps depuis l'époque de
Saint-Pétersbourg et puis la dernière
Poutine c'est que derrière Prigogine il
y a tous ces blogueurs
ultra-nationalistes ultra militaristes
qui sont sur la même ligne que Prigogine
il y a quelques généraux dans l'armée
qui sont pas loin de partager le point
de vue de Prigogine sur le fait que la
manière dont l'offensive est menée par
Monsieur shoego et guérinov n'est pas
des des plus efficaces la lumière
Poutine en fait il est aussi menacé par
cette espèce de d'ultra droite en
quelque sorte donc il est un peu coincé
et il fallait qu'il se sort de toutes
ces contraintes il était obligé de
marquer le coup il trouve cette solution
médiane moi je pense quand même qu'il
soit un peu affaibli de l'épisode mais
disons qu'il a gagné du temps quand à
gagner Prigogine il va certainement
sortir renforcer d'un point de vue sans
doute popularité auprès des militaires
et son exil en entre guillemets en
Biélorussie sera peut-être de courte
durée il a montré en tout cas quand
quelques mois finalement parce qu'il est
sorti de l'ombre en septembre dernier il
est devenu une figure avec qui il faudra
compter à l'avenir en Russie